tout de suite la revue de presse
avec Julien chaïda bonjour Julien
bonjour
par cette femme à l'honneur dans votre
revue de presse une Française écrivaine
prix Nobel de littérature nous en
parlions il y a quelques minutes et
évidemment Philomé quand un français
remporte un prix Nobel c'est toujours un
événement surtout quand il s'agit d'une
récompense littéraire l'événement
s'affiche en Une de Libération et de
l'humanité une référence évidente à l'un
des plus célèbres ouvrages Dani Arnaud
c'est la 16e fois qu'un auteur français
reçoit la prestigieuse récompense elle
rejoint Camus sortent Sartre ou encore
Modiano mais c'est une première pour une
écritaine Française a mis un nom femme
de lettres nous dit libération vous
allez le voir à l'instant c'est un joli
jeu de mots qui résume bien son œuvre
littéraire engagée politiquement engagé
contre les ségrégations sociales et puis
surtout pour le droit des femmes depuis
son livre elle a toujours puisé dans sa
propre vie sa propre expérience pour
évoquer la condition des femmes on
parlait de l'événement à l'instant récit
glacial de son avortement clandestin
dans les années 60 qui a d'ailleurs fait
l'objet d'un film tout récemment on l'a
vu dans le sujet de Nina Masson une
littérature de l'intime mise à l'honneur
de la presse régionale avec le Dauphiné
Libéré la presse dans son ensemble salut
le courage de l'Académie suédoise de
récompenser cette oeuvre à l'heure où la
lutte pour l'égalité homme-femme n'a
jamais été aussi actuelle ou encore en
moment où les Iraniennes se battent
malgré la répression féroce justement
pour leurs droits Annie un nom en bas de
une du Dauphiné comment justement a
réagi l'intéressé Julien et bien comme à
son honnête commençons d'habitude en
fait en toute modestie elle dit j'ai
appris la nouvelle quand j'étais en
train d'écouter la radio imaginez ce que
ça peut faire vous êtes en train de
regarder France 24 et on apprend que
Philomé Robert a remporté le Prix Nobel
de littérature ça doit quand même être
un peu étrange comme sensation elle
s'est dit honorée et se dit investi
d'une très grande responsabilité mais le
plus important pour elle est bien c'est
de ne rien changer surtout à la
toutefois l'envie lorsqu'elle recevra
son discours son son prix à Stockholm
lors de son discours alors a quand même
toutefois à coeur de défendre une
nouvelle fois les causes qui lui
tiennent à cœur si longtemps on reste en
France Julien avec un tout autre sujet
on a beaucoup parlé de risques de
pénurie de gaz et d'électricité mais
c'est peut-être bientôt l'essence qui
pourrait manquer oui c'est le Parisien
qui résume le mieux cette situation coup
de pompe au station essence plus d'un
millier de sites en France sont déjà
touchés et des fils d'attentes s'allonge
de plus en plus notamment en région en
francilienne et comment est-ce qu'on
explique cette situation et bien la
France ne manque pas de pétrole mais de
main d'oeuvre c'est la conséquence d'une
greffe qui paralyse trois des cinq
raffineries contrôlées par le géant
total énergie au total
en tout il y a 8 raffineries sur tout le
territoire nous explique le quotidien 20
Minutes les salariés réclament une
augmentation salariale de 10% pour
compenser entre autres les effets de
l'inflation et surtout après les
bénéfices records enregistrés par
l'entreprise sur l'année 2022 parmi les
régions les plus touchées en parler de
l'Île-de-France mais aussi et surtout en
tête les hautes France le gouvernement
ne parle pas de pénurie mais de tension
temporaire tout est dans les
terminologie l'essence devrait bientôt
revenir dans les stations et sur les
autorités d'où la une un peu moqueuse de
la Voix du Nord toujours plus compliqué
et aussi encore un peu de patience
s'ajoute que nous reviendrons sur cette
situation beaucoup plus en détail tout à
l'heure dans l'info avec Christophe
danse on change de sujet nous partons
comme promis pour le Chili donc
peut-être déjà pour la Chine presque 3
ans après l'apparition du covid 19 la
presse retrace l'histoire de l'homme qui
avait tenté d'alerter sous la
dangerosité du coronavirus effectivement
peut-être que ce visage vous dira
quelque chose sinon je me rafraîchis la
mémoire il s'agit de Lil way Yang il
était totalement log à l'hôpital de
vourane en 2019 il est décédé quelques
semaines après l'apparition des premiers
cas sur le sur dans la ville et on peut
lire dans le New York Times une très
longue enquête qui retrace les derniers
jours de ce médecin ces jours il avait
tenté d'alerte sur l'apparition d'une
épidémie d'origine pulmonaire et
d'origine surtout inconnue lui n'avait
que son travail de médecin et de
citoyens il n'avait fait que son travail
de médecin et de citoyens en demandant à
ses collègues de se protéger comment
rappelez-vous les autorités chinoises
ont-elles réagi à ce moment-là et bien
nous dit le New York Times le
responsable du parti à l'hôpital de
bouran aurait jugé l'information trop
sensible au pour être rendu public
résultat le médecin en question a reçu
une sanction disciplinaire et
l'injonction de faire des excuses
publiques auprès de l'hôpital et
décidera trois semaines plus tard d'un
arrêt cardiaque trois semaines durant
lesquelles la Chine aura fait la sourde
oreille avant de reconnaître aux yeux du
monde la dangerosité d'un nouveau virus
respiratoire la suite de l'histoire on
la connaît le Chili donc c'est incendie
sur l'île de Pâques oui parfois il
suffit d'une photo pour commenter un
fait d'actualité celle que publie la
terre serra le quotidien chilien est
suffisamment parlant de regarder ses
statues qui ont fait la renommée de
l'île de Pâques entouré d'un paysage
totalement noir si carbonisé plusieurs
de ces visages monumentaux ont été
sérieusement endommagés nous dit-on au
total plus de 100 hectares du parc
national de Rapa nouilles sont partis en
fumée indique le gardien les habitants
sont évidemment sous le choc ils parlent
de dégâts irréparable impossible en
effet de réparer des pierres d'origine
même en y mettant une fortune pour le
maire de Lille l'incendie est forcément
d'origine humaine une enquête a été
ouverte il s'est produit trois mois
après la réouverture de l'île au
tourisme alors que l'île dépend très
fortement de l'économie locale après
deux ans d'isolement causés par le covid
19 merci beaucoup Julien Saïda pour
votre revue de presse on peut retrouver
évidemment sur les plateformes
habituelles de France média monde